speaking of green a team that wears
green and makes its fans faces turn
green on a weekly basis the new york
jets and
look
here's what they're doing and this was
beautiful last night during the game the
jets announce that they will cut le'veon
bell and
cbs cuts in
james brown they throw to james brown
from the game in nashville and what what
does he say the jets have released
le'veon bell no no no no and you look
around look around twitter jets have
released le'veon bell no no no no no
it's not how it works can't release
le'veon bell until four o'clock eastern
yeah right today
you can announce you're going to release
him he's not released yet he's still a
member of the jets and oh why are you
florio complaining about some obscure
rule bingo no
we've seen this time and again we've
spoken about this time and again this is
the baited hook being tossed into the
pond in a last-ditch effort to catch a
fish
because once the team's out there that
may have interest in le'veon bell know
he's going to be released there is a
reason to try to trade for him even if
the jets are paying 95 of the contract
even if you're only giving them a
conditional seventh round draft pick
there is still a possibility that he's
going to be traded and we're saying this
out of experience chris we know this
we've seen this typically there's a
report that comes out in the morning
team's going to cut a guy and by four
o'clock they don't cut him they found a
trade partner and the jets announced it
last night to have all the last night
all of this morning and most of the
afternoon to see if someone will offer
them something
to take le'veon bell off their hands
that's why they did it yeah there's no
reason to make that announcement last
night there's no strategic reason to do
it other than to make it clear
here it is now's your last chance if you
want le'veon bell other than having to
potentially box out other teams to try
to trade for him or try to sign him once
he's cut right i mean it makes it you
know totally public totally out there
gets fans in certain cities maybe
clamoring like oh we should sign that
guy i mean you know it does all that
type of stuff and you're right some of
those teams who might have been
maybe just thinking i'm we're going to
lay in the weeds and wait till he gets
cut and then see where it goes from
there
oh okay now you know he's going to be
released or whatever else i mean now you
know there's gonna be some competition
and all right maybe near you're gonna
pony it up pony up something just to get
him to make sure you have the rights to
him i don't know now i think most of the
league probably knew already that he was
on the trade block it sounds like just
and but no he was they yeah they were
calling right now
right and exhausted all options and i
think but now this is this is the last
ditch this yeah sure this is your this
is your hail mary pass to try to get
somebody to trade for yeah definitely
that and i also think it was like one of
those things where probably at the end
of the day they were just like let's cut
the cord right now i'm sick of like
dealing with this
i don't even want to have to like kind
of deal with it tomorrow let's just get
it out there now and be done with it so
we'll see i mean yeah nobody's in a
trade for le'veon bell and pay pay him
six million dollars the the the jets are
gonna have to pony up some cash i would
imagine and then the other thing is is
just yeah where does he land and
honestly mike the way i look at it and
for a guy like le'veon bell
um
if he doesn't get traded
he better be very careful what he picks
here this is this is a big this is a big
spot in le'veon bell's career i mean
le'veon bell is this fall for this close
from falling to obscurity and just
really like being career over if he goes
to the wrong team here and shows he's
not worth the damn on this team either
they'll be about the end of his career
or he's certainly going to have to go
back to the drawing board and change his
game and change the way he's you know
his body everything because it hasn't
been good but when you look at it too
the funny thing is mike i feel like
only some of the good teams in football
need the running backs to where he could
end up on a team like if i mean if i'm
seattle i'm calling le'veon bell if i'm
kansas city i'm calling levy on bell if
i'm the pittsburgh steelers i'm calling
le'veon bell those are three teams right
off the top of my head right away where
i go they're really good that would make
sense for le'veon bell to be successful
they can win games and they actually
have a need at the position and i'm
interested to see where it goes
bell told me last year at the trade
deadline the
texans the chiefs the packers the
steelers and maybe the eagles were
interested in trying to do something to
trade for him they just wanted him to
reduce some of the guaranteed money for
this year he wasn't willing to do it
now if he's cut here's the thing and
it's in his best interest to be cut
because yes
he gets to keep all of the balance of
his salary even without reduction as
termination pay under the cba he gets
the 6 million even if he makes two
million over the balance of the year and
he probably won't make that much with
another team but he gets to keep all of
it so it's better to be
cut than traded at this point right and
yeah he can go wherever he wants what
about the bears what about the bears
definitely wouldn't the bears be a
perfect destination they're trying to
goose that offense tariq cohen's out for
the year le'veon bell would be perfect
in chicago
assuming he can still play right we're
assuming he can still play exactly right
we don't really know i mean we really
don't we haven't even seen the ball in
his hands enough or enough of a
workhorse type you know game plan around
him to know what he really is is he even
close to the guy we saw in pittsburgh
before the year he sat out on football i
mean then
he was definitely one of the two or
three best running backs in the game
right now he's nowhere near that and we
don't know what he has left in the tank
and as we've seen with running backs two
three years you could be a totally
different guy and not be like the
superstar you once were so uh the bears
though my good one by you you're right i
left them off they certainly could use
it that and it's an offense that suits
him it's spread out they're run games
that kind of way too to where it's a
spread out offense and kind of a zone
blocking and just pick your way where
you want to go um but he needs to make
sure that if he does get released
he sets himself up for success because
that if not next year it's it's league
minimum and
it's going to be like
you got to make the team it's not even
going to be like oh yeah you're the
you're the workhorse number one
superstar it's going to be like now
we're going to see if you can even make
the team and we'll go from there
and if league minimum is all you're
getting offered then that may be when
you walk away all together because it's
not worth putting yourself through it
when you have that much in the bank when
you've made that much you've made 27
million over the last two years yeah you
don't need to play for the league
minimum
i this just shows you how bad it's
gotten
for the jets and le'veon bell because
look why not hold on to the guy for the
next three weeks and see if a high-end
running back with a contending team
tears an acl that would open up a trade
market that may not otherwise be there
right now but it's gotten so bad that
they've got to cut the cord now why not
just make him inactive for the next
three weeks why not wait and see i mean
i'm not going to name names but it
doesn't take a whole lot of brain power
to come up with the list of the
contending teams with high end running
backs who are a big part of the offense
who if they're done for the year all of
a sudden there would be potential
interest in le'veon bell why do it now
when you've got two weeks and six days
until the trade window closes that that
tells me chris how bad it is yeah you're
right it's got to be got to get in the
hell out you're right it's got to be
pretty they don't want them dealing they
don't want them in the building anymore
they've realized it's become an issue i
i mean
we got to get the hell out okay but i
like your idea of maybe just
making him inactive for a few weeks and
doing that not a bad idea oh yeah yeah
make him inactive and then see what
happens and then you get something for
him if somebody gets desperate
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports